foreign
hey the hackers or your system stays
blocked recent years have seen a
ransomware epidemic with an organization
attacked every 11 seconds
part of a growing cyber crime threat
there is actually let's say threats that
are politically motivated
there are threats that are motivated by
people of let's say Bad actors and they
are in there for the money let's say
and there's also the threats and they
are closely related to each other that
involve let's say misinformation
campaigns
as lives become ever more digital cyber
security risks have multiplied
endangering our privacy and Bank
balances Power and Water Supplies
Hospital operations even National
Security
cyber attacks are increasingly used by
hostile Powers against Democratic
institutions
Parliament is determined to ensure EU
citizens businesses and governments are
better protected this piece of
legislation is the biggest renovation
Europe has ever seen we will see lots
and lots of cooperation between law
enforcement between cyber security
companies making sure we have an
ecosystem not just to passively watch
how we're being attacked but to actively
stop attacks from occurring
MEPS have signed off on tough harmonized
rules obliging authorities and companies
to Boost network security and improve
the Integrity of the internet
covering Banks and key Public Services
the measures will also extend to sectors
like food medicine and waste management
common level of cyber security in the EU
is crucial for a functioning internal
market and peace of mind
[Music]